[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Friday
howdy how's it going so this is well our
revisiting the Mortal Kombat series yeah
yeah live streams are gonna be doing
because you know one of combat 11 is
coming out in about a month and it's so
soon we were like you know what let's
replay every Mortal Kombat game yeah why
not let's see where it started where
where it came from where we're going
where did you come from where did you go
Johnny Cage yeah just to kind of get an
idea yeah see things and and all that
I'm also just excited to go back and
play some of the exactly so we're
playing the Mortal Kombat arcade
Kollection yeah which is um it's not
available anywhere anymore it was only
on the it came on the 360 ps3 and pc and
then they dont sell it anymore the
unlisted it you can't it's not backwards
compatible you have to do some weird
hack we have a good old three so yeah we
had the only reason we're able to play
is coz been happy to have bought it you
know you're able to redownload it but
you can't buy it anymore so we're not
only we're gonna be playing the old
Mortal Kombat screen fighting the old
Mortal Kombat's on 360 controllers with
these I came in here and John Luke's
like I got my fight pan out and I'm
ready to great let's let's take it take
it back right into it yeah yeah so we
played a little bit of these to kind of
like reef Emillio they're rough they're
rough to play again this is back from a
time where I didn't know how to play
these games very well and learning how
to do Liu Kang's shadow kick was like if
people want to throw us like we're good
we're gonna pull up some guide stuff
because we definitely want to like make
sure we want to mess around we want to
do some fatalities we want to do some
grit so people have anything they want
us to
do any recommendations please let us
know we want to this is kind of a fun
stream don't expect hi-oh tossed you
older fighting games they go by so quick
good like I don't know any of who's like
so that's a good thing we do have move
lists here if you want to pull them up
okay I got two moves back back and down
back okay I could do that and then
fatality is hope right trigger and then
up up up and sweep range okay we've got
it I'll try it we got those friendships
oh yeah babe Allie's so yeah there's my
spear okay I was I wasn't about to let
that happen though I got my teleport
actually you know what coming back to
this now after playing through one one
two and three while we are like practice
someone get the teleport
that's fine I mean I'm not I want to I
want to see that oh yeah you got that
that last ditch circuits doing it but
it's not working like I did it once but
then it's like yeah and canceled it
oh there it is I didn't you don't know
what your face I don't know okay
everyone's everyone's positive
GameSpot's awesome babe a ladies orb a
ballad which one I did they introduced
baby thinks it's what one comment three
is where they got crazy with it
cool let's get going then yeah oh I got
to pick my guy yeah yeah I guess with
all the character yeah I'm the champ
so shadow kick has got to be the same
thing it is all the time yeah shadow
kick is all you need to know that and
hold on
yeah I have to put this I have no no
that's fair that's fair there's gonna be
a lot of us pause right trigger and a is
the input for all you do is his regular
doesn't that's weird
okay and we got ality it's not that hard
that's just Ford Ford Ford X close okay
I'll try to remember that so we got a I
got my moves
yeah I was doing my split whoa these are
complex he's got his knife throw oh no
his his cannonballs always got like the
the weird like like spinning oh it's
just a full 360 basically down for ya
yeah it's just a 360 like rotation first
I was like what the heck and then hold
right trigger and then back forward okay
so it's weird because oh there it is see
this the most important thing is getting
that and the shadow kick there we go I
did the spinning kick oh that's what I
wanted yeah you oh you smug son of a
[ __ ] look at you go look at him okay
I'm in the I'm in the flow of it now I'm
yeah you've got it I've downloaded
Mortal Kombat 1 what system are we
playing on we're playing on the 360 it's
the arcade Kollection so this is like
the original arcade versions we have
like a couple we have a finesse version
a Mortal Kombat like one yeah
which is like obviously like a lower
quality version oh okay it's do it do it
do it it was forward forward forward X
we'll get it we'll get it behind me it's
okay there's no fatalities there's no
room for it it's so fast so quick talk
about the stop-motion how good these are
Oh Oh someone's saying the plug-and-play
version is apparently the best console
for really that's fascinating
that's because I'm like plug in play
versions are they usually like mmm
terrible I was about to say uh literally
before we came out here Ryan I was
talking to me about pit fighters like
yeah it's it's it's all there it's
perfect dude I will you know you you me
should switch at some point cuz I will
say playing with this white hat it makes
it not I'll do it
no it's way better really do the d-pad
actually does I'm making it work though
like I'm I I can actually feel like I
can do what I want to do except I don't
know what I want to do because I don't
know any of the moves but I think theory
I think like I do stuff quarter circle
back and X is you're you're freezing
maybe I look for backward X I can
probably look at that might be faster
let's down forward and on board a
because okay punches are on X and a and
not X&Y back a B whoa that's like that's
intense
there's a lot of buttons there I love
the just old yellow this is a flight I'm
not okay I got the best slide I'll do
that though oh there you go don't walk
up and tap we got a little fight that
yeah my strength is so high so um we're
not gonna be able to get like reptile
because reptile you have to do like
double flawless victories for like six
rounds or some nonsense to get him like
you fight him and then you can unlock
him or something like it's I'm so happy
that I remember how to do that it's the
most important thing oh hello ah dang I
didn't look it up that's great Fox wants
us to uppercuts thrown in the pit that's
a good call is that original it should
be okay hopefully we get the pit well
we'll try and do that you know I'm good
Sonia going okay yeah yeah yeah there we
go all right cool perfect timing
excellent
how do i do my bicycle cake so I know in
three it's holding me down for four
seconds the most important move so no I
don't have the bicycle you don't even
have a bicycle kick here yeah but uh
okay these are easy moves though forward
forward also to fatality can be done
anywhere and it's just the dragon comes
in okay so Ford for X and for ya you're
removed I'll hit up scorpion on you
after this there you go yeah I love it
there you guys waiting for it I love it
Oh No yeah yeah alright this is a guy I
gotta bring it back I was cooking mk1
come on man dude I didn't plan k1 I
played MK uh it was too like my bowling
alley had mk2 yeah and that was the one
I played so I was actually thinking
about this when we were playing I think
I might have played mk2 shooing three
the lows you got it you're an uppercut
me oh yeah oh there you go
I think you I think I think you'd still
do it I'll do I have to do it again I'm
sorry all right
sixty one's hard like getting it to like
work correctly it probably is easy with
you because you have the I have an
analog of an analog I do not do let's do
the scorpion versus oh yeah this is the
but you have to do
No ooh
The Mortal Kombat uppercuts are cool we
were talking about we're playing beta
it's it's about the the sweeps the
sweeps in uppercuts uppercuts I mean
that's like even @mk like 9 that was
like the dirty like yeah uppercut do we
want to look up one of our fatalities
and try and figure it out like uh yeah
it's a go for like I want to okay mine
is forward down forward X and when
you're close I'm close I'm gonna look
mine what fear is up retrigger up up
good that's not bad at all I'm sweet
it's not what I wanted come here
the best combo an old Mortal Kombat
history the how do you mess with the pit
fatality regular fate I'll I it it's
okay it's alright we'll get back we'll
get back to it
yeah come on there we go
no no no oh there we are
you know what I'm taking it back I was
worried about these but like upon
playing more time they're kind of broken
especially for tripling against the AI
oh yeah okay you got to do it man you
gotta do it
no ah there's like no time won't get I
was too close I'm supposed to be in
sweet opening sweet maybe that's why uh
that's price see I want to go back to
Johnny Cage is the one I felt I feel at
home when I'm playing Johnny Cage
Riviera since here for a while because I
think I think we've we've hit all the
characters now so yeah
did I win you know I don't know we'll
never know my favorite thing about MK 9
is how they recreated all of the old
stages yeah
like modern graphics and it looks so
good jeez yeah do once you get once you
get like they get on you like there's no
there's no out of it oh no oh that lasts
a really long time
it really does like as soon as you've
got the fries down for for subzero
you're good you're kind of yeah yeah oh
my gosh BAM
oh no cost costumes fit well in MK 9
whereas in MK x I felt out of place I'd
agree you did a little yeah that games
got like a like a gritty dark color
palette respect look at the time it
looks really good but like now I'm like
pretty looking yeah like more comics
like a very colorful series oh I didn't
look at my thing but graphical fidelity
wise I think it looks like the best but
yeah I don't like the art style or
direction although I feel it the faces
haven't held up well like they look too
shiny yeah yeah there's like they're
like they're really sweaty or something
sweater you're shining it's kind of
weird I don't know like I feel like the
MK 9 or MK x graphics of aged poorly
yeah but I really like the look of
eleven reasons a lot of fun yeah I want
like as mam's back forward a is the only
one you need teleport back forward a is
lightning okay
oh it's back I thought it was back
forward a I've just been doing it the
right way the whole time
here I'm gonna I'm gonna look at my
fatality cuz I'm still unique a true
treasure that's easy sport for Dex yeah
poor for Dex yeah
Oh get out of here with that yeah where
am I oh I'm still here
oh no oh so now we're now we're into it
like we're yeah like we've gotten into
it
yeah it's great who's your favorite
character Merle comment to play us it's
Johnny Cage without a doubt he's just
he's a he's a gross boy you wonder why
Johnny cages an m3 kuzzik fired the
actor home play time God at least that's
the word on the street no no they
actually did they fired him because he
did we did we got a fatality I can't
believe I've pushed forward three times
an ex fantastic what a time so easy
there's the Risen thinking about that
compared to like how it is now there's
like no it doesn't feel as impactful oh
sure like when you figured out their
coach yeah oh my god it was really like
you watched the guy do it yeah how did
you do that man yeah
Wells again said I'll say something
sorry we oh yeah so like they they fired
the actor who played Johnny Cage because
he appeared in an advert for a rival
fighting game oh that was kind of taking
like shots at Mortal Kombat and
specifically like the ads were kind of
like referencing like hey even Johnny
Cage prefers this game that's marketing
in the 90s was something else but I
think there was also some like
misunderstanding as well I wouldn't even
look into it more but I remember that
being like a thing and I'm like oh
that's do it again one more time all
right I feel I feel bad because you're
explaining a thing and I just find guys
okay
what the give them the people what they
want play please Shaolin monks we will
we will we are gonna get there we're
gonna play every game and then includes
all of the terrible yes so we're gonna
try to play every Mortal Cheerilee yeah
I I remember having an Ori time with it
and we can we can co-op it which is
pretty exciting
you know I'm gonna get the run back on
this because I feel like I can do
scorpion a lot again it's like four down
forward and we're done for next back I
think it's off of my side so it's gotta
be forward yeah cuz back back on all the
yeah yeah four down for that camera
they don't actually even sub-zero
Chronicles even sub-zero Chronicles yes
even Special Forces all right so I'm
gonna remember that hold right trigger
and then up up in sweet Mirage
not kidding me come on with your head in
the game
it's a good weight guru is just an AI
you beat at the end right yeah you won't
try doing it like get to go I'm summing
up no use up the difficulty because some
boy did it cheats
yeah the defaults I'm gonna call Mortal
Kombat a long time ago the game just
cheats it does it really does
even I'm King 9 okay that's like that
free mode is it's kind of [ __ ] it is
pretty crazy to look at how far the
graphics are problem boy oh yeah and I
mean this even still like this is very
distinctive like you look at this and
you you know it's little comment right
away great YouTube recommended me a
video is I think it like I was like a
Mortal Kombat stuff because of a stream
so a new recommended me a do it yes oh
yeah that's the psychotic one oh and you
did it to Sub Zero that's great shipping
we're getting all the good stuff right
it showed me a behind-the-scenes video
of them like getting the actors in the
makeup and like doing like the motion
capture I mean it's like a really high
quality video to like it looks great and
you can see them like they're painting
like Jax's arm yeah like it looks like
you know like a robotic arm and stuff
like it's great I like super into it and
we want to want to try the arcade after
sure after this one do you want to do it
or do you want me alright
okay well this is where we can hit we
got do the pit whoever does it has to do
it there it is that's the button I'm
looking for oh and you can just spam
that I don't know I think I just got
like a double kick for it oh dang
doesn't work Dow no you got those up
it's the Mortal Kombat about that
uppercut man
I got it I got it oh geez oh geez
the combos the real Wallace no oh you oh
you gotta do it there we go there it is
perfect ice um okay so before we move on
was there anything else people wanted us
to try and do what's gonna take me in
with yeah yeah you think oh boy done all
right we'll have you do the ladder the
nice thing is we can just put in another
quarter yeah right
I do a friendship friendships on this
one uh you'll have to look it up because
if it's not in the move list here then
we don't have access to it actually that
might have been only the different to
friendship isn't - okay we're gonna do
MK vs. DC Universe as well we will you
bet yeah so they I think this is still
so not normal
oh really yeah it's okay if it if I lose
and I can go back and pick Johnny Cage
or at least say I feel like I know a bit
more or I can just see here and trying
to spam that out while we trade off each
round we can do that yeah do it
Sonja dang do the thing take me back
all right we're gonna let it run down I
think that's how you have to do it game
over that game over screen
it's got scary skeletons everywhere all
right
ten wins three million points oh do you
think we'd be able to do player one with
the white sticker uh it might be kind of
weird though okay so you gotta set that
AI right did you there's endurance stuff
oh my goodness
uh maybe a we're gonna do the PSD games
yeah we're gonna do them all we're gonna
try and do every Mortal Kombat game
that's all right that's okay we don't
have to get to the end we'll just give
it a little shot and then at a certain
point if we're struggling we'll move on
I guarantee there's gonna be struggle
but we're gonna look good while we're
doing his own tactics yeah
sweep it sweep it sweep it yeah yeah get
them get them get them
yeah yeah yeah heck yeah we're in there
oh yeah my dude just so good
this is man I feel I feel bad anytime I
see Sonia and Johnny Cage fight
I don't like it yeah ever since that
scene in in nine word you out I'm
checking you out
Tim dinner like yeah I could it gets
real weird in MKX where it's like Oh
Sonya Blade why would you watch us split
your daughter in half yeah your legs
that's horrifying you yeah like it's
kind of funny when she does it to like
Johnny Cage she's like ah marriage I'm
alright yeah especially cuz they have
like a rocky relationship in that game
in there but to the kids I'm like that's
weird yeah it's like kenchi why would
you cut your son in half with your sword
you're magical
wait let's say my sorry he can't he
can't punch Sonya oh that's just uh
that's canon yeah but like it doesn't do
anything it just he just gets down on
the ground and that's it he doesn't
actually try that's really weird
oh man he's got kicker it's the only
thing that'll work now there you go
I mean like he like the actual animation
doesn't play out for the nut punch
because Oh fighting Sonya oh that's
interesting
like he just gets down and does the
splits and is like huh-huh
uh would you like to try the second
fight in our pain yeah I'll try yeah we
probably should move to to at some point
no we will we will I don't we want to
waste too long in the arcade ok Tuesday
I was cheap I feel like a lot of the AI
and the originals were you know when we
go to you should try this teabag is all
right well switch the controller's
around it's so much better
Carly krylon this game was released back
in 92 yet the models are more realistic
and Mortal Kombat 11 can't get any more
realistic than real people
yeah no realist there's a part of me
that wishes they'd just kind of stuck
with this like the entire time like they
never stop using like live-action models
so the the last game that the people who
are making Streets of Rage for made is
done with scanning real people into it
and I think it's the most recent example
of it the game is fantastic
also dongdong ever die the true
spiritual successful in the bottom at
perfect I'd like to see smoke pop up in
me - I really like smoking - I got got
hey there's that boom hey we found him
appreciate that man
alright let's take it to - moving on to
- we're pond 360 people were wondering
because the 360
the only way to play it these like the
easiest way for us to play these these
intros oh yeah yeah totally forgot 500
years ago ha man these are great look at
that stuff
I feel like the music could be louder
you know what I mean like like in the
aisle just in the gay way they designed
it cuz these are all arcade games and
this is the thing that would play yeah
yeah this is here to entice you right
yeah I'm enticed look look look
continues did they spell continues with
okay I was something I wasn't paying
attention either I hope they did oh this
is this is getting me into it yeah so I
think this is the mortal comment that I
played most at my friend's house yeah
apparently they did yes so we're good
there you go we got a flashy logo too
they really up the production values on
this one huh whoa I think we want to
I've gotta go Johnny peach oh no you
want to do scorpions observe first yeah
yeah I mean there was a lot of
characters to go through now we've got
hope it sounds way better - there is a
uppercut fatality on this yes there we
go
oh you can hear that get over here that
get over here Sperry get over here oh no
I supposed to go for the uppercut ins
give it this is uh this is a market
improvement introduction qualities also
they change the uppercuts uh which feels
right to them
it does feel right it's definitely the
how it should be
that dolt you can't so is it the same
fatalities should we look that up so you
probably look at that yeah oh by the
lower right they added like a multiple
fatalities your own men ships babe a
letís State fatality oh you actually go
to situate the state race help Jesus to
God he's it complicated
yikes yeah I love all the ninjas looked
at mk2 to them yeah they look really
good are you even playing yeah yes board
forward out yeah they change his stuff
forward forward down I'll try Ford
forward down why take me in what do I
got up up X from half screen or down
down up up I do that anywhere yeah uh no
nope up something already forgot my
[Laughter]
board for down who did the voice acting
things I know Ed Boon does
Thanks oh no I didn't hold blockings uh
ask a well get it's the first one we're
good all right back in all right I'll do
Baraka Baraka embossers smoke gin yeah
right yeah hold on I've noticed
something weird all of our jumping and
moving sounds are the same sound just
like scorpion Oh God
did a murder on me yeah I did to fight
it's all good I drew my hat throw back
forward a back for a okay dude this
d-pad man hold on wait a minute you
couldn't Oh blocks on the button over
here not on the trailer okay do you have
to use the it's no good oh yeah no spark
oh dang winds give wanna see babe a
ladies rock is really cool like said a
dude with like
[Laughter]
whoa surprise
stop do it man I even look it up clap
we'll go through all the countries and
then I think maybe we'll come back I'll
come back and we'll try and do some
stuff so pick jacks i'll do some rap top
oh heck yeah imagine recording this in
studio yeah like tell these people live
up to do all these these crazy like the
rest of these moves are kind of complex
okay energy wave
no thank you ground pound is holding see
they had all these hold buttons for
things so gotcha Graham is still here
that's good alright and fatalities right
recharge or a okay alright yeah we're
gonna play three after three is kind of
what we're getting even building up to
yeah yeah gotcha
my sum up Jax do it there we go don't be
a baby about if I might need to switch
over back to that boy oh no that's fine
yeah no that was us worried about that's
the good stuff
how do you lose his arms I think the guy
ripped off like I feel like it's got
either be Toro and Montero the best
combo when I work on that it's right
there yeah it's awesome
there's no time no this is totally fine
I just can't do it
[Music]
Oh Oh Mac doesn't 9 there you go yep
because he was never there so weird like
I love all that [ __ ]
change it up Graydon's rings here play
school oh oh there oh I see you've
switched your character mid-match I'm
back soon
oh I didn't look anything up okay you'll
see that lightning and you're good yeah
exactly
uh what's up - were playing on we're
just playing against each other yeah I
haven't done Johnny Cage oh so gotta do
Johnny Cage yeah look at that dude dumb
guy so yep oh he doesn't do it - katana
either he just stops here like hold
something just to be sure
yeah just doesn't do it he's a classy
man you know oh there's this um gather
smoke you see smoke ass on
areas still air doing this thing oh no
oh yeah well sweep and throw fan fan fan
okay it's just a lot of X's here
yeah I'm looking I want to make sure my
fatalities still the same thing down on
448 so I'm not enough to do that Oh No
there it is as those jumping kicks no
didn't those those uppercuts the more
common uppercuts are so good knows a
Molina yeah actually
usage is a true Chad by some kicks in
this one right I yeah yeah it supposed
to be okay all the rest of it super easy
dang yeah okay
teleport kick got it okay no oh just
yeah it's like you gotta hold it for
like exactly four second oh it takes
forever one two three four so I think
you can eat for as long as you're
holding it for four seconds you can let
go of it any time okay so it's not like
an exact timing thing there you go yeah
oh my goodness out of the air
No yeah oh no no I'm supposed to
uppercut
oh so match with blue Canyon Raiden oh
oh no I don't know it
it's definitely underlying you're not
out of time now down forward back back
wide my geez
I'm came one two and three are the best
and will always be I remember having a
good time with this where every good
time I'm having a pretty good time
playing him now actually yeah we were
kind of worried we were like playing it
yesterday just to sort of like get
ourselves acquainted and we were like
[Music]
you want to a Raiden Liu Kang because
they both do sure really cool yells heck
yeah so dumb favorite 3d era game
[Applause]
[Music]
ah people can be found man I'd have been
really good a voice acting Mortal Kombat
actually have a thing for now dang oh
man see so I think we've played everyone
played everyone blew people wanted a
babe a letís right yeah and some
friendships so we got a try let's let's
pick a character that we're we're
feeling I mean I was feeling Liu Kang
for sure heck yeah
[ __ ] will do some will decent look at
fighters alright so what I'm gonna so if
I want to do a babe ality dungeon down
forward back be Becky and then a
friendship is forward back back back to
you I'll do a friendship first okay cuz
that seems like it'd be easier to
remember forward back back back deep
200 is real easy
suppose my friendship shoot yeah yeah
it's either down or back let's see what
happens this is when we get into the
proper like this one we get competitive
with this is we gotta mean dude dope
going in doing the thing come on Johnny
Cage get it together
feelin it we fight keep the kicks goin
you definitely should do Johnny Cage
miss friendship I remember being
it's this backpack B right yeah maybe
you just didn't do the time that's fine
people keep doing it yeah we got oh wow
I didn't realize it's been 40 minutes
yeah well keep though we're gonna try
and do a couple friendship yeah before
we move on no no Sonja she's here I
gotta save her look exactly like the
beginner character because it's like
just forward forward and then why we
want to save Kate oh no I don't need her
he's a ghost boy wished it the shadow
king went a little bit further
my shadow kick show Oh your friendships
down down down not back
Oh down down down why four downs and a
why okay okay okay
this is the sweeps man sweeps in these
uppercut it was a good-looking uppercut
though I panicked
it's ok let's do it again we'll do it
again run it back just Minds like this
or back back back be thank you crime
crimes gonna just keep yelling mad at me
for it back back back
heck yeah get it going know it was gonna
be flawless I'll let you in case special
forces best game we'll find out when we
play it on the stream there you go those
weren't even actual crotch punches there
oh we haven't been doing enough well
dang maybe I just pressed Y at the wrong
time maybe maybe I need maybe I need to
not go as hard as I maybe need more time
maybe maybe we'll move on yeah read
alright Johnny Cage Hereward is terrible
at this more time come on I believe I
believe in us I believe in Johnny Cage I
believe
I believe no yeah
fun fact that works even if you get
knocked down as long as you're holding
beads it work just still comes out to
fight oh no oh no oh no come over here I
dare you hold on I got a double check
double check I make sure I'm doing this
right it's Ford back back back be
anywhere we're gonna do it I'm gonna
blame you I did it I did it right I know
I didn't blame these Xbox sorry guys
we'll try to do some stuff in three all
right threes threes the three is the the
one that you build torch three is the
big deal or use threes good breeze the
good one it's the ultimate exactly okay
yeah you got to do it superfast I don't
trust I don't trust the accuracy of
these 360 d-pads I won't be honest
look at the skulls everywhere combat and
a sinister laugh that it alright this
guy expected more of an intro yeah I'm
quite flashy I thought said player to
always free and I'm like oh wow that's
look at all of these characters now I
know combos we can unlock the other
three so we'll definitely do that I do
want to look up one for the the first we
can just try to get him Oh
striker let's go through the new
characters first well I'm gonna pick a
ball because next Riker I was balling
out during the MK 11 stood looking stir
I love strikers oh man I'm not you're
not gonna let me not gonna let you do
that I'll let me shoot this guy are you
so I remember that combo specifically
because it's the easiest thing to do
come on shoot your gun nope we're we're
striker at you know bring striker back
dude they put him in nine and it was
great yeah
I got these local needs these hi grenade
baton toss rapid rapid gunfire 4x yeah
that's what I'm looking for feel like
the matches actually go longer in this -
yeah I have a lot more health you
definitely do
striker died it's the perfect time to
bring him back they had a man there we
go this is like the beginning of X is a
like ball died - man take it go off
everyone at the end of MK 9 no - ready
your gun there we go yeah just screwed
off into the sky dumb character I love
them fight there it is give me another
one a lot of laughs oh no I didn't look
it up all right you didn't even follow
the people Sandra Mac high punch low
punch uhh block low kick high kick dang
that's a lot I mean that's for it's for
the unlock code okay cool let's get
their other characters then we'll do the
unlock codes yeah we got we got some of
the the cyborg ninja dudes coming in now
that's good my wolf is weird
go Sindel cuz the game chose for me
fine
okay that sounds good
she do like grabs their hair and stuff
she was a 9-2 right yeah yeah it was
night wolf oh yeah pretty much all the
characters from 1 2 3 r & 9 so it's a
really good roster it really is whoosh
that was like a real combo yeah I did
like a thing for a minute oh nice figure
that out yeah yeah yeah yeah did it
again loves me oh okay I think I've
downloaded Sindel I've got a hair toss
definitely got her Oh figured that out
that'll be good also that sound effect
is very dramatic
yeah right oh I've reflected it back in
myself
Oh No
above back I'm gonna do my animality mu
Ford Ford down down ah I did it
a real animality I hit the button there
might be more requirement soon Cyrax
stuck in the sand back there is really
good yeah it's pretty good yeah let's do
we done yet look at all that we all the
cyborgs cuz I look the whole thing in
this one yeah do you wanna do you wanna
be which do you have anyone that you
like in particular I mean smoke okay how
like kind of like siren all right cool
she's got the got the net and stuff I
really like how in like three they like
Aaron nine they had like what they look
like before they turn into like ninjas
or into like cyborgs yeah there's like
this weird like tragedy to it where they
were like converted to like cyborgs
yeah flipping the bombs
that's a weird input okay oh yeah yeah
it's my animality after doing the merci
input okay
[Applause]
so full smoke right now
I love though just incomprehensible
robot noises that's pretty good fight
[Applause]
well I can't believe you did it again
dang it's irax again with the net why
I'm trying not to use the net because I
realized like have using the net so
that's definitely the beginning part of
a combo geez geez Sark's is really cool
yeah go do the Armageddon fatality I
don't remember I spent so long it's it's
really cool like actually like I I
really like when you've kind of threw
the idea out of going back to through
all these games cuz like fun yeah okay I
know I don't remember all that stuff I
don't don't think about it as much
one fight like how took me through games
but your boys got that get over here
down pat oh yeah yeah you got the unlock
bet that old-school input it's not back
forward it's just back back it's also
the easiest thing to rely on remember
when scorpion had an axe yeah got like a
sword right makes more sense of an axe
it's not a very ninja thing to have yeah
oh of course
yeah good effort
I was like maybe if I try to like semi
remember an old one maybe it'll work but
yeah mk4 brought in weapons it was kind
of like a weird semi 3d thing I forgot
the change how sub-zero looks great fox
is wandering in being Jordan is the only
mean Jordan of height for Borderlands 2
the entire office and different about it
I was just not hype off the trailer I
just thought the trailer was kind of
weak it's still curious to see what
they're gonna do with it I think the
rest of the office seems rather
indifferent about like oh I'll play it
but I'm not like oh yeah I didn't really
see anyone who was like I think Tam was
maybe interested I'm still very curious
about it it was more than just like
after five years of life hey man they're
making a new Borderlands I saw the
trailer I was like pull me away but I
want to see game yeah action they're
doing a thing we haven't done any runs
though I don't know how you - oh that's
a good button to have that's all the
same
[Music]
okay I got missiles ooh nice nice
this is like the most great school like
cool [ __ ] ever from ho-oh
hundred hundred it's a ninja robot that
shoots missiles from that shoots
missiles from his chest do that ninja
takes off his face and he's got
reptile-like is it's the kind of stuff
that you just like drawing your notebook
or like ah I love it
this is so good my wrist madness is
remaster for one and handsome collection
pretty excited since games not optimized
for newer cards Oh I mean realized it
was I've played in a while um but I
imagine yeah that'd be difficult if
they're not like keeping up with it it
might be like cards like run on newer
systems so that's actually really cool I
I'm interested in playing that original
yeah remastered cuz I'm a lot of choice
for the first order Lance
do you want try to do one of the codes
yeah it's probably too late now yeah I'm
not sure I don't think so maybe Shing
soon but shanks and I think we've done
like or being urn out scorpion a simple
yet oh yeah we gotta do the scorpion
sub-zero match oh yeah yeah we gotta do
it every every time oh man to make ursus
Borderlands 1 is very important to fight
me um I'd ever liked the tone of
Borderlands 1 better but I do
mechanically prefer to I put a lot same
oh yeah we didn't play Jay Z and play
Jade thank song with
[Laughter]
I'm so good I like how it it like
lingers after he lands from missing the
move so also uh the cyrix is still in
the backgrounds yeah this is you know
usually like counsel that all right you
got hit the button ok Appa Jade okay and
then you pick I don't know
sub-zero I think we've done shanks who
you though will do will do sub-zero
score because that's the way you got to
do it that's I don't think anyone's
Pokeno maybe or maybe we do I don't know
we'll find out shoe though we did place
you though yeah okay what are the usual
inputs should probably look up like how
to do his like main gimmick
yeah want you look it up
one flaming skull two flaming skulls
three flaming skulls in a corruption you
morph in a Stryker Ford Ford Ford Y all
right I mean we try it out I'm here
strike the time oh the original like
character that has other characters
moves I think some fighting game nailed
it
what is a Run button yeah now I have no
idea what what is the Run button I know
that you can run miles do some codes
yeah we don't have them up though you're
right let's just pull it up we'll do
scoping in sub-zero wait so you get it
pulled up to okay and I look how people
were mentioning them but we'll pull them
up here we go oh that's for the Genesis
watch what the get after this I guess
oh yeah your eyes closed my eyes closed
hold on I wanna see what scorpion
peasant's it doesn't have anything
that's different it's just the same
stuff teleport punch is more alive
unfortunately I don't know like how to
translate these codes into what we're
currently I didn't even look at
fatalities at platformer research group
you could call I'll try and do it let's
try and follow up key codes Xbox 360
okay team FAQs calm
what you gonna do we're gonna we get
this this goes all right y'all finding
it there's so many good fun go go down
to excellent nope
a silent combat high smoke
that's human smoke point okay here we go
unlock or Mac Molina and I'll fight why
you look it up okay here we go oh we
both have to do it yeah it's it's a six
part code you see first match all the
time after hit three we can do it
the way they've presented this yeah so
okay so you gotta lose okay I can I can
do that yeah we're gonna give this a try
here this is for Mac so why a right
bumper the X for you
I gotta hit it I can hit Y once a twice
a bumper three times enough buttons you
know we get the stage song and its
really complicated holy crap oh then
there's a note that says the combination
for getting her Mac is by far the
trickiest abilities these are complex
geez
we gotta let the timer run out yeah yeah
the timer run out try we'll try and like
Molina all right man do it what are the
buttons here why twice a twice right
bumper twice we got it's it's almost up
now so I'm gonna have to get these are
the weekend we can do it let's give it a
real a real run back this time I think I
don't think we I think we have to go
into arcades so we're gonna have to you
know it's a fire okay it's a two-player
yeah boy so strong yeah this this is
where I thought you did it
fight like that that's that's like just
a good move overall all the time that
lasts forever yeah that's a really long
Wow sounds good I feel like the Run
button is just right trigger while
you're like moving or something but it's
not going for me that's a good kick I
can't break out of this and spin it out
I guess
oh man next time you have a boon over
ask him to enter one of the codes here
absolutely you ready to read it off dude
I'm ready okay okay all right something
I have to lose the fight here okay
I should just pick the hardest
difficulty cuz it just worked me fight
me katana fight me all right so what's
our plan of attack gonna be first we're
just gonna you're gonna read it I'm
gonna wait for me yeah yeah I just have
to do it as quick as you're reading yeah
so this is a guide to have like two
people who do these codes cuz yeah way
it's ridiculous fight brain and give
this like a shot and see if we can do it
cuz oh my god we really should do a feat
I like that idea a lot but that gray fox
said next time Boone's over have him do
the coach yeah yeah you do it hey this
is all great and good talking about
Mortal Kombat 11 time unlocking I want
to see you do these codes at boon I want
to see if you can make this happen
because you know it did take him a while
okay ready yeah I'm squaring up I'm
ready for it all right
why twice a twice right pump or twice B
6 times X 4 times y twice a twice
oh right bumper no that's so no time
how how it's like I like barely got
through my set oh my god let's do them
at the same time I have I think so oh my
god cuz I had enough time to enter mine
and I are like 3 seconds left that ain't
happening Oh bummer times 2
oh did the bumper not even happen maybe
it's not bumper maybe it's trigger
because trigger actually says it says
bumper or B what if the people who wrote
this wrong that's just bad let's do
another match for two and then I think
we'll call it good
that's that's ok I'm fine yeah it's one
of the unlockable characters isn't
Johnny Cage so like here I am doing
everything I can
yeah you need to enter the code at the
same time yeah then there is no way
oh I'll have his was like spinny move
that launches people up in this one it's
you actually had throw gotta teleport
Rowan spin is there it's forward down
back we should ask Peter for a game
genie that's sounds good
we almost we're almost trying to find a
way to like get these games to work if
we didn't have them yeah we were trying
to figure out it was like beer do you
have a thing that lets us play our cable
hookup the arcade cabinets in the stream
machine make it work maybe I would have
just try to find a copy of like a MK
trilogy on ps1 yeah Oh God come wow
you're so cool but I don't
that's fine down down up why I'm half
screen forward up up why love bumper see
I use that's one of those ones you gotta
hold the block to do you got told the
block o solution hold Blancas it keeps
you on the ground keep down the ground
here right hi I do a jump and kick I
threw my hat I was throwing spear I know
where you've been Colin's a couple moves
yeah I'll admit I don't like remember
any of these but it's true oh man how
long ago did these games come out
backwards-compatible yeah unfortunately
no you can't even buy it anymore yeah
which is I don't think it will ever be
by our stupid penis but we did jacks
oh yeah we didn't do this jacks for sure
now he's so strong all right I think do
you want this to be the last one yeah
I'm down oh god cheese I'm falling right
back into my usual Jarvan usual [ __ ]
out of the air I love them
Cole's great oh yeah they won't go
that's that's the kind of stuff for you
or you don't want to do like one actual
last one was like like a character that
you were you're feeling more can you
feel I got like a real run back cuz I I
picked a character that I was feeling
that's very it's very don't you guys
having for lunch no I have no idea I
don't know yet either
oh no with the missile counter get out
of here
oh maybe spoke too soon fight that got
you before you still I like that I can
juggle you like that that's real dumb
dang yeah what do we call it there yeah
this is good to me you feel it feeling
it
alright alright I'm down oh that's fun
that was a lot of fun yeah I don't I
don't know what Mortal Kombat games
we're gonna be hitting up next week but
I think probably due for and maybe 500 K
in 4 and 5
well we'll figure it out but we're gonna
be doing every Friday and leading up to
Mortal Kombat's
11:11 we're gonna be playing all the
Mortal Kombat games sort of revisiting
the series so stay tuned for that guys
and it's also a good weekend another
we've got some videos going up dirty our
DS coming up later today um I think the
suck hero review is finally going up on
YouTube yeah if it's not there yet it
should be soon there is a Rob Robin Jake
I've been working really hard on a
octane guide for apex legends and I
believe that went up this morning yeah
so check that out and thanks for joining
guys and we'll see you next time bye ago
I can't miss you
[Music]